so today I am here with the amazing the
lovely the talented the beautiful the
greatest Brin cartelli I love her and
we're going to do an AMA which means ask
me anything we're going to ask each
other three questions about literally
anything the fun part is that we have
both come up with these questions
ourselves and we both have no idea what
the other person is going to ask so you
know send some nice do you want to go
first
I guess that okay well change my first
question is what are your three desert
island albums that was one of my
question I changed it to something else
man now okay that would be Deva any
Linux probably Miseducation of Lauryn
Hill Thornhill probably Joshua Tree you
too yeah yeah are there good ones yeah
okay so now I'm gonna ask you this
because this is more important okay what
three food items would you cuz I have
mine but what are your three food items
that you can't live a if you just have
an endless supply of where are the same
okay really weird but I love love like
roasted broccoli and I ate way too much
[Laughter]
chicken chicken nuggets can't even lie
chicken nuggets what's your favorite
dick hey mustard Oh chick-fil-a sauce
this is actually one I always think
about because I see it in interviews all
the time and I always think about asking
everybody this cuz it's so interesting
to me what is the last thing you do
before you go to bed every night is
there one thing well friends I was
single for many years so I have children
when and how one makes children it's
generally what I did before that's real
and it's not weird it's natural and this
is my America loves you
[Applause]
so wait no quiz one of my questions
because I'm genuinely want to know what
are you listening to now the quarry
inspired by oh I'm listening to so much
right now I'm loving the new Harry
Styles album I love that fallen so I
just I love it so I'm listen to that and
I'm also listening I keep going back to
them because sometimes I listen to so
many things that have lyrics and like
words I listen to you and I feel like I
need to escape from word so I listen to
like heavy-metal instrumentals I love it
what is the rowdiest city like craziest
loudest city you've ever played on the
craziest place I think that we've ever
played a style paulo sao paulo is like
in brazil it was like crazy and like i
cried because I was well not shocking
yeah but I cry because I was overwhelmed
because I literally didn't have to sing
like I could have not sang one lyric all
night like every album track every hitch
like everything mate they knew every
riff like it was and it was thousands of
people was crazy and I'd never been able
to play there before and it was this
crazy like show that I I just was
floored
so my third and final question this is
this is a really a question do you know
awesome you haven't your mom is so cool
I'm telling you I work with a lot of
people and especially young artists that
have like parents like right like she's
legit so cool like are you
are you aware like a panel I am 95% of
the time I am aware my mom calls I'm not
kidding or to be like your mom and I
know cuz I've been around you've been
staying at my house mom's can be
annoying they can get on you and they
can pick it here and try and pull things
out of you but that's only because she
loves you and like literally y'all have
the greatest relationship and I just
it's literally your mom is like mom
goals for me oh it's pretty rad it was
really questioning anyway I love you I'm
so happy
come here thank you for waiting back
when you release that bad ass album
you're making thank you it's so good
anyway thank y'all so much for hanging
out with us this has been AMA ask me
anything not the AMA ones but she will
be there one day winning anyway this was
bring cartelli and I and a peace out
guys ah I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this